Jordan:
Hi, I'm Timothy.
This is
Scalable Structured Markup.
Who here knows
what that means?
A couple of you.
All right, well,
I added another title,
because I thought maybe I'd make
it a little bit more clear
what this talk
is really about,
and it's about putting
more knowledge into your site.
I think that's
a really interesting idea,
and over this,
the length of this talk,
we're going to look
at different ways to do that.
We'll see that putting
more knowledge into your site
can be as simple
as just identifying the data
that is already there
and not adding anything new,
just be like,
"This is what it is."
The richer the markup,
the more control you have
over how your site appears
and the more cool things
that can be done with that data.
By the end of the session,
you'll be able
to mark up your pages
so that they can appear
in search engine results pages
with Rich Snippets.
You'll be able
to test that markup,
and you'll be able
to tell Google
how often it should crawl
certain pages
and when things change.
This is all about getting
more control over your site,
how your site appears
in search results,
and when it gets updated.
And, of course,
at the end of the talk,
I'll give
a better understanding
of maybe where
this is all going.
Does that sound like fun?
You all just had lunch,
didn't you?
[laughter]
All right, so here's some
interesting bits of information.
Up there are the hashtags.
If you would like to tweet
this session,
I encourage you to do so.
These are some hashtags
to identify your tweet.
Also, there's a link
for feedback.
I'd love to hear how you feel
about the session,
and there's a link to where
the session is going to live
after today.
That's me.
Hello.
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google,
and you can find me online,
and you can @mention me
@timothyjordan.
All right, so today this is what
we're going to talk about.
We're going to look
at the past.
Where does it all come from?
We're going to look
at the present
using Rich Snippets
and using Sitemaps,
and we're going to look
at the future.
What's next
for all of this markup?
So, the past.
This is how the Web looks,
oh, I don't know,
circa 2000 or so.
You edited some pages.
You uploaded them
to your server,
made a Website.
Google crawled those pages,
when it felt like it,
and returned links
to your pages, as appropriate,
on the search engine
results page.
The problem was that
the Snippets on the results page
were relatively boring.
I mean, they were
a good summary of the page,
but they didn't share
the richness
of what those pages
actually had on them.
Every page
looked the same,
and you had no control
over how it looked.
So, the question was,
how could you get more control
over the search engine
results page?
How could you get it to know
more about your site,
and how could it provide
that knowledge to the user?
That brings us to today,
the present.
Your site probably looks
more like this, right?
You've got a database
on the back end
that drives your pages.
You can mark up those pages,
identifying the data
that's already there.
Google, when it crawls
those pages,
can then see
what's on those pages,
what actually
those items are,
and it can display those to
the user in an interesting way.
Maybe that page
is a recipe page.
It can show
a recipe Snippet.
It can add ratings
where they exist.
It's the richness of that data
that you get a say in now,
and we can do some other
cool things with that data
that we'll look at
a little bit later.
All right, so let's talk
about Rich Snippets.
We'll dive into this topic.
Rich Snippets have been around
for about two years.
In fact, two years two days
from now.
And over that time--you can see
I have a timeline,
because this is a presentation,
and you need a timeline.
On my timeline, you can see
that over the last two years,
we've been steadily introducing
different types
of Rich Snippets,
and we've been introducing
different ways for you
to mark up those Snippets that
we recognize and will crawl,
from recipes to events
to prayer times last week.
So, here's a couple examples.
This is a search for stuffing.
And you can see
I'm looking for stuffing,
and I get this response.
This is on the whole page.
This is one of the responses.
And you can see the richness
of the data in this Snippet.
You've got a rating,
and we know how many reviews
that rating comes from.
We've also got a clear
description there as well.
So, when the user looks
and sees summary, summary,
and then a Rich Snippet,
that really stands out to them.
Here's another example.
There's a search
for Drooling Dog Bar-B-Q.
And, of course,
I got 26 reviews,
and I also have
a price range,
what you can expect to pay
at this restaurant,
and I've got bread crumbs,
which locate this page
in that site.
We know that this is
a barbeque restaurant,
and we could
probably also navigate
to other barbeque
restaurants.
And in some cases,
we can combine Rich Snippet data
with other data we find
to further increase
the richness of the experience.
And you see a really nice
description at the top,
and you'll also see
some other data that we found,
like an image and other places
where this is listed.
So, those are Rich Snippets,
and you can see the value
of this to your user,
and you can see
how that would translate
into more traffic
and a better experience.
All right,
so let's drill deep.
Let's look
at some markup types.
Now, with standards,
in general,
there's always very strong
opinions about which is best.
And I'm not going to tell you
which is best,
but I'm going to give you
some pros and cons
for three types that we read
and we'll scan for
when we're looking for
structured markup on Web pages,
the first of which comes
from RDA,
and RDA has
a really great design.
It comes from XML tradition,
and it's very general.
You can express a lot of
different things with RDA--
sorry, RDF.
There's RDFa that does
an attribute-level mapping
of RDF to XHTML.
And that's cool.
So you get all the power
and design of RDF.
The problem, though,
is that sometimes this can be
a little confusing to write,
and, in fact, in user studies
with Webmasters,
they found
the nesting structure of RDFa
to be particularly confusing.
That's when, say, you have
an entity such as an event,
which includes an entity
such as a location
that's nested
inside the event.
That particular markup
can be a little confusing.
Another option
is microformats,
and this is just
a different place to start.
Publishers generally
say this is easier
to identify their data
in existing HTML docs
using microformats, but
it's not as general as RDFa,
so you can't express
as many things.
And there's one more--
microdata.
And microdata
has the general expression
of entities like RDFa,
but it also maps
more easily to HTML,
and this is
my preferred method.
I like it, mostly because when
I'm reading an HTML document,
I can parse this easier,
and so maybe that's just
a personal preference.
This is the one that I'll be
using in examples today.
Speaking of which,
let's take a look at an example.
I want to give you
a URL first,
and this is the Rich Snippet
testing tool.
It's at
/webmasters/tools/richsnippets.
It's a really cool tool.
You can go there
and put in any URL,
and it'll tell you
what data that it finds
and gives you
an example Rich Snippet,
if it can find enough data
to construct one.
Also, on the left of that page
is a link to our documentation,
which will clearly list out
all the different types
of structured markup
that we'll look to and map
to a Rich Snippet,
and what are
the different parameters
that are required
and optional,
and it also gives examples
for each.
And, again, this is what
a Rich Snippet looks like.
We're going to do an event.
These are the properties
for the event.
I'll come back to this table
several times,
so don't worry about
copying it down real quick,
but you can see there's a number
of different properties,
and they're all
pretty straightforward,
from summary,
to URL, to location.
This is a page
without markup,
and it's as we would expect
a very simple HTML page to be.
We've got some data,
and we've got some very,
very basic formatting
with line breaks.
I'm going to take a look at
this page in the Snippet tool,
just to get a default
baseline expectation.
So, I've got
structured-markup.appspot.com.
This is just a static
app engine site,
so I've thrown some static files
onto app engine,
so that you could play
with them, if you'd like.
You want this URL.
Oh, you want it bigger.
How's that?
Okay, thank you.
The no-markup page
looks like this,
and you can see
it's very basic.
I just have some line breaks
in there.
It's not pretty at all.
I wanted to make sure
it was super basic
so that we could see the markup
as it gets in there.
I'm going to go ahead
and copy this URL and paste it
into the Rich Snippets
testing tool,
and you can see
there's insufficient data
to generate the preview.
That's what we'd expect, right?
We don't expect it
to find anything,
'cause, well, there's nothing
to find there.
So, let's take a look at it
with some data.
I'm going to add in
three bits of data--
the two required types and
one of the recommended types.
And I really strongly recommend
you add a location
to your event as well.
We've got a summary
up at the top.
That's required.
And we've got the start date
down there in the center,
also required.
And the location, of course,
is where this event
is taking place,
and that's going to be
a nested entity.
Adding the markup,
it looks like this.
And let me take you
through it line by line.
At the top, we've got
an itemscope.
That itemscope
is super important
and really basic.
If you have a div tag
or any tag
that surrounds all the data
for that entity,
that's where you put
the itemscope attribute,
and it's going to tell readers
that everything inside,
everything a child of that tag,
is the scope of this item.
Does that make sense?
Oh, good, there's nodding.
I like that.
The next thing is
we've got an item type.
We just got
to clearly indicate
what kind of entity this is.
In this case, it's an event.
Now we've got item props.
This is the item property.
We've got three,
as I mentioned--
summary, start date,
and location.
And the data
contained in those tags
corresponds to that parameter,
that property.
Let's take a look at the nested
one down here at the bottom.
You'll notice that I have,
next to the item prop location,
another itemscope
and item type.
Since it's nested, we're going
to add another entity
inside that parent entity,
so it'll need an itemscope
and an item type
to indicate it.
In this case, we're going
to list an organization
as the location
of this event.
And, of course,
it has an item prop.
I've just added one--
the name.
That's required.
So, let's take a look
at this live.
I like saying that.
Over here, I'm going to
the required markup link,
and it looks like this.
Notice,
it's the same Web page.
I'm going to copy this
and paste it into
the Rich Snippets testing tool,
and you'll see
we have new output.
We've got, here in the center,
the Google Search preview.
So, if we were to return
a Rich Snippet
in the search engine
results page,
it might look
something like this.
And down at the bottom
is my favorite part.
It tells us all the data
that it found.
So, if we thought we were
marking something up
and it's not listed here,
there's a problem
somewhere along the way.
Likely, we put in
the wrong item prop,
or we put that attribute
in the wrong place,
or it was looking
for the value somewhere else.
And so, at this point,
we'd look back at our code
and see if we could
find the error.
Really straightforward, right?
Okay.
All right, let's add in
a few more properties.
You'll notice
some of these properties
are going to change
how the Rich Snippet looks,
and some of them aren't.
But since we have the data,
we might as well mark it all up.
So, in this case,
I'm going to add a URL,
the description, the end date,
and the event type.
All of that data
was already on the page,
so I'm just going to
mark it up,
and it'll look
something like this.
And you can see I've added
the description right there,
added the item prop
and a span.
I've added the end date.
Both those dates
have the ISO time
and then a readable time.
And down here at the location,
I have the locality.
Oh, and an event type down there
at the bottom.
And we'll take a look
at what this looks like.
So, you can see
a couple things have changed.
One, I have a lot more data
down at the bottom.
Another,
up at the search preview,
you can see it's added
the locality to the location.
So, a number of things
didn't make it to the Snippet,
but it's still good that
we've indicated to the world
that those are on the page,
and maybe we can take use
of those in the future.
But then some things do
update the Snippet.
See how that works?
And all I've done
is added a few attributes
and a couple span tags
to surround data.
I've not added anything
to the page,
other than markup.
So, let's talk about scaling.
This is the easy part,
actually.
If you've got a site like this,
where a database
backs your pages,
and, hopefully, that database
is a field-level database.
If it looks something like this,
then it's easy.
Likely, you're not writing
your pages.
You're editing templates.
So, where we have the summary,
location, and start date
in an event field
in some database,
we can just add those
to the template
and make sure
that the markup's there.
When we change the template
for, say, product pages--
maybe there's 5,000 of them
on our site,
but one template--
we mark up that one template,
and all of those product pages
get the markup.
This is kind of obvious,
but I think
it's important to note
that when you edit
your templates
to include this markup,
you've added it
to your whole site.
Another thing, Sitemaps.
This is also kind of
a scaling issue.
We'll get to that.
This is where we are.
We've got a database
driving a site,
driving the Google index,
driving search results,
and the Google index
will find pages on our site
as it can
and when it can.
But wouldn't it be cool
if we could tell Google
what pages are on our site?
These are all the pages
I want you to know about.
Wouldn't it be also cool
if we could tell it
these pages change daily
or these pages change weekly?
And that's what
Sitemaps are about,
and they've been around
for a while.
Essentially, you've got your
database driving your Sitemap,
and your Sitemap
goes to the Google index,
and then Google knows
when to look for new data
and where to look
for new data on your site.
Let's take a quick look
at an example here.
First off, links--
super important to have links.
Sitemaps.org is where you
can go to for the spec
that Google and other
search engines use,
and you can use
/webmasters/tools
to get a little bit
more control
over the Sitemaps
that Google sees.
A typical Sitemap
has these properties.
You've got a URL set
that encapsulates everything,
and then you've got
URL entries.
In those URL entries,
you may indicate the location,
the last modified date,
the change frequency,
and the priority
of the page.
All these are
really straightforward.
The one that I do want
to mention particularly
is the priority.
This is a scale from 0 to 1,
and by default, it's .5,
and they're relative
to each other.
So, if you list
all your pages at 1,
you haven't really done
anything.
But if you tell Google
this page I want you to have
a bit more priority for,
say, my home page, right,
then maybe
some of these product pages
that are only updating
monthly.
And this is what the example
might look like.
So, I've just added in
the home URL of the examples
I've been using so far
on app engine.
I've added in a date,
that it changes daily,
and I've added
the default priority.
And, of course,
this is really easy to expand
to include the other pages
on my site as well.
And maybe once I add those,
I realize my homepage is a .8,
and these other pages are a .7,
just slightly less in priority.
And that slide came
a little bit early.
I want to introduce something
really, really cool,
but first,
let's look at the tool...
which is here.
So, I've got a couple Websites
in Webmaster Tools.
And I go to site configurations
and Sitemaps.
Now, in Webmaster Tools,
before you can start
doing anything,
you need to have
your site claimed.
That site needs to be yours,
and that's so not anybody else
in the world
can start telling Google
about your site for you,
when you don't want them to,
and that can be as simple
as adding a little file
in the root directory
of your Website.
Google scans that
and knows that you have
right access to your server.
Once we've done that,
we can submit Sitemaps,
and that's what
I've done here.
I've gone to submit a Sitemap,
and I've entered in my URL,
and that Sitemap appears.
And every time
that Sitemap changes,
I can come back
to Webmaster Tools
and hit "resubmit,"
put a check mark next to
that Sitemap and hit "resubmit."
That's cool.
Google will know the data
that I want available,
and it'll know when I feel
it should take a look
at that data.
You can do Sitemaps with feeds
as well, which is pretty cool.
And once you start using feeds,
you might start to think,
"Wouldn't it be cool
if Google can know
about my data on my Website
as it changes?"
I've got a database
backing a feed.
That feed updates
as my database changes.
It would be cool if Google would
know every time that happens,
and that's the slide
I showed you.
We have another thing available
to us called PubSubHubbub.
Who here knows
what PubSubHubbub is?
A lot of you!
That's great.
So, I've got a bunch of slides
that are going to be review
for all of you
that raised your hands.
We're introducing today
that our Sitemaps
and Webmaster Tools
will support PubSubHubbub.
So, when you put
a hub in your feed
for the Sitemap of your site,
Google will read that
and subscribe to that feed
and get those real-time updates.
It will then know
that your site
and that Sitemap
are ready to crawl.
It pretty much
looks like this.
You have the Sitemap.
You add in PubSubHubbub
so that a fat ping
just hits Google
every time something happens,
and then Google knows
that your site is updated
and can check it
when it can.
All right, I'm going to go
through PubSubHubbub quickly,
because there were
a lot of hands.
Slow me down
if you don't get anything.
PubSubHubbub is a really
straightforward protocol
that solves
a very specific problem.
If you have a feed--
And I want quick, timely updates
about that feed,
before PubSubHubbub,
what I would do
is pull that feed.
Every 30 seconds,
or 10 seconds,
I would download
that feed again,
and I would say,
"Has anything changed?"
If nothing's changed,
then I don't do anything.
If something has changed,
maybe I bubble that up
to a user-facing action.
But the problem here
is that you have
lots of publishers
and subscribers.
Let's say 1,000 subscribers
to one publisher,
and all of them are asking
every 30 seconds,
"Are we there yet?"
Right?
This would be annoying
for a road trip,
and it's annoying
on the Internet, as well.
Wouldn't it be cool
if the publisher
can just tell the subscriber,
"Yes, we're there"?
And that's what
PubSubHubbub does.
It works with three things--
a publisher, a subscriber,
and a hub.
Get it?
PubSubHub.
And, of course,
the "bub" is just for fun.
What will happen is
the subscriber
will ask the publisher,
"Can I have your feed?"
The publisher will respond
and include a link to their hub.
If the subscriber
is PubSubHubbub aware,
it will then subscribe
to that hub,
and this hub will do
a little bit of a dance
to verify that the subscriber
actually was subscribing,
and it wasn't an attack
to overload them with data.
So, it'll say,
"Are you sure you wanted this?"
The subscriber
will say yes.
From then on, the publisher
is going to send data
to the hub,
and it's going to do it
one of two ways.
Either the publisher will notify
the hub directly,
or the hub will continually
pull the publisher
in that pulling method,
which isn't a big deal now,
'cause now there's just
one person pulling,
and that person can do it
at a much higher frequency,
and that publisher
will give it the data.
Once the hub has the data,
it sends it to the subscriber.
That's it.
It just pushes out a fat ping
and a post.
This is your data.
This is the update to this feed.
So what'll happen is,
when your site has an Atom feed
and it has a link to a hub,
when Google subscribes to that,
every time you make a change
to your database
and that gets updated
in your feed,
that feed will push out
to the hub.
It will then push out
to Google...
right through.
Pretty cool, huh?
And Google will then know
that it can recrawl your site.
And, of course,
this works.
PubSubHubbub is a great protocol
that works at scale, too.
So it can work with
a huge number of subscribers.
Let's take a look
at a quick feed.
This is an Atom feed
with a link,
which is just right up there.
It's a link,
a real link to the hub.
And this is
actually a live feed.
If I go to...
I made a blog.
It doesn't really have
anything interesting on it,
except, for our purposes,
this link down here.
Blogger, as it turns out,
has an Atom feed by default
that includes PubSubHubbub.
So, I can actually
take this link
and go to Webmaster Tools,
and you see I've added in
that link to that feed,
and it is subscribed
through PubSubHubbub.
I was actually playing
with this last night.
I would post a new message
on my blog,
and then sometime later,
I would just see it
automatically show up here.
Pretty cool, huh?
So, that's pretty much
all you need.
You create a Sitemap feed,
and that can be an RSS,
mRSS, or Atom.
Use a hub, a PubSubHubbub hub
and indicate that in the feed,
and then add the link
in Webmaster Tools.
Data in Webmaster Tools,
by the way,
is updated after Google
crawls the site.
So, there may be some delay
in actually updating your blog
and seeing that
in Webmaster Tools.
Don't expect it
just to pop up.
All right, so let's talk
a little bit about the future.
What's next?
So, this is us
with Rich Snippets,
and PubSubHubbub Sitemaps.
We've got
a database-backed Website
that pushes to the content
of our pages,
and that markup
is also structured
so that those entities
are identified on those pages.
The database also updates
a Sitemap,
so Google knows what our
content is and when it changes.
And then we've got
this cool stuff
over in the search engine
results page.
And what we can expect
in the future, for sure,
is more Rich Snippet types,
perhaps.
We just added prayer times,
and there's a lot of
different discreet entities
that would be cool
and interesting to show
in the search engine
results page.
We're also going to do more
with that data.
For example, we can include
that data in vertical searches,
and we've just recently
released this feature.
I don't know
if you've seen it yet,
but I had a screenshot earlier
of a stuffing search.
You'll notice, when I look
down here at the left,
I can narrow my search
by ingredients,
and that's because
these Webmasters have identified
the ingredients in their recipes
with Structured Markup.
So, as I select,
say, I don't know,
turkey,
maybe I don't have turkey.
Maybe I have sherry,
and maybe I have steak.
Here is a grilled flank steak
with mushroom stuffing.
That sounds fantastic.
And I can indicate I don't have
more than 60 minutes.
Apparently, that takes
a while to cook,
or the other fear is that
it doesn't exist for my diet.
[laughter]
You can see
how this is really cool,
that we can do
not just Rich Snippets.
Not only do you get more control
over how you look
in search engine results,
but we can do cool new things
with that data,
like this vertical search
with recipes--
and it all starts here.
By mirroring the data
in your database
on both your Web pages
and your Sitemap,
and on those Web pages
using Structured Markup,
your Website becomes
more like your database.
By telling Google this
right away,
that data is more known
and more useful and available
for your users.
The more this happens,
the more the whole Web
starts to become
more of a database,
the more we can start to do
really cool things
with that data.
Pretty cool, huh?
All right,
so, to summarize,
the practical elements of this
talk is markup is super easy.
You don't have to add
anything new to your site.
You just have to tell us
what it is.
Scaling
is pretty straightforward.
All you really need to do
is edit your templates
instead of the end pages.
Markup is good.
Yeah?
Rich Snippets
are really cool,
and vertical searches
and users appreciate them.
Not only that,
but you have more control.
You now get to tell Google
what data is there,
using Sitemaps
and using structured data,
what data is actually
on the page
and what pages have data.
And, of course,
the Sitemap tells Google
what pages should be crawled
and when they've changed,
so they can update them.
And this all leads, again--
this practical application
that happens today
is more control over
how you appear,
and Rich Snippets
and Sitemaps give you that.
It allows you to control traffic
and engagement,
and it gives you more control
so that using that control,
people know what's so great
about your pages.
You let your users see
the richness of every page
when they're looking for them.
I think that's pretty neat.
All right, that's pretty much
all I have to say on that,
except for the answers
to any questions you may have.
I hope that was interesting
and straightforward,
but I would love to talk
about it further.
So, we have a microphone
in the center
and a microphone
way over there.
And if you want to go up
and ask some questions,
I'm here to answer them,
and we have some other Googlers
who are experts
in this area here
available to answer as well.
Daniel up here might be
popping up and saying hello.
Yes.
man: So, if we've got
a new kind of entity
that we wish Google would make
into a Rich Snippet--
Jordan:
Yes?
man: We happen to be
a real-estate site.
We would like
"three beds, four baths"
to appear
in a Rich Snippet.
My understanding, will we need
to build an industry consortium
to make a standard
around the microformat?
Is that step one?
Jordan:
Well, there's two things.
One is being able
to identify the data,
and, yes, you've indicated
that, right?
Like having
microformats or microdata
able to specify that is great,
and microformats in RDFa
are really good for this,
because they're already
pretty general.
The other thing is convincing
Google that that would be, like,
good for the users.
And so the best step there
is to go to the Webmaster Forum
and make it known,
"This is a Rich Snippet
that we think would be really
valuable to the users,
and we're ready
to mark this up,"
or, "We've already marked
our pages up with this."
Would you add
anything to that?
We can share a mic.
Daniel: I've never talked
to your chest before.
[laughter]
Jordan: I'm sure they can bring
up a mic in a sec,
but I'll hand this
over to you.
Daniel:
Great. Thanks.
Yeah, I think
that's a great direction
that we want to pursue
in the future.
One of the great things
about both RDFa and microdata
is that you don't have to form
an industry consortium.
You can mark up the data
that you already have
on your page in a forum
that makes sense to you.
That starts
the conversation, right?
That starts the conversation
when you post a link
in a Webmaster Forum.
That starts a conversation
with other Webmasters
about what data is interesting
to other sites.
It starts a conversation
with Google
about what you're
able to mark up.
So, I would say that
that's the beginning--
thanks a lot--
and over time,
we'll have some better answers
to this question.
It's a critical part...
Jordan:
Hello, hello.
man: Well, I'm certainly open
to the idea.
What you just described is,
"Oh, you should just
mark up your site,
"and then post
in the forums.
Maybe someone will notice."
I'm not sure
if anyone's going to notice--
A random post
on the Webmasters Forums?
Really?
Jordan:
I read the forums.
[laughter]
man: All of them?
They get
a little noisy sometimes.
Daniel: Seriously, there are
a lot of people at Google
who do read the forums.
But, yes, I think you've really
highlighted an issue
that this is a person-to-person
negotiation right now, right?
That part is not scalable.
That's why Timothy's talk
on Scalable Structured Markup
didn't include that topic.
And so, yes,
it's socialization.
It is developing
a groundswell of support,
but we recognize
that that's not ideal.
So, we look forward
to coming up
with better answers to that
over time.
It's a serious problem
that we recognize.
[man speaking indistinctly]
man: That is
an industry consortium.
I need to build an industry
consortium of people who--
man: It's not
an industry consortium.
It's a Wiki page that you go to
and a process that says...
man: Okay, I'll post
on the forum,
and I'll post onto Wiki.
Maybe someone will notice.
Daniel:
Gentlemen--
Jordan: Clearly, we all feel
passionately about this.
We don't all have microphones.
Daniel:
So, please, yes,
please come up afterwards
and chat.
Jordan:
Yeah.
Daniel: I would love to have
a longer conversation with you
about how to
make that work better.
man:
All right, thank you.
Jordan:
Yeah, please do.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Jordan: All right,
let's go over here
for the next question.
man: A common response
that I see on my test page--
on my test page or
the testing tool that you have
is, "We couldn't find
the subject of your page."
So, I've included maybe
too much structured markup,
and I wasn't able to tell you
the exact subject of the page.
Say, it's a profile page
for a person,
and I really want this
to be the highlighted noun,
and I included too many of
Spinal Tap's upcoming concerts
in the sidebar and videos
or whatever else.
So, what do you recommend
for highlighting--
It could be an area roll
or something--
the subjects of the noun
that you really care about
for that page?
Jordan:
That's a very good question.
I don't have
an immediate answer, do you?
Daniel:
Yeah, that markup, ideally,
in a large
scalable site, right,
you have records in your
database, as Timothy described.
You have records
in your database that describe
each part of the page.
Focus on, you know,
what that page is about.
Focus on the record
that backs it.
This markup is really
specialized right now
to pages that are
single-item pages.
It's possible to do more,
but, honestly,
Google isn't so good
at that right today.
Jordan:
That's a really good point.
When you markup your pages,
do you open up the
Webmaster Help Center article
for that Rich Snippet type
and try and hit that,
or do you just
add the data?
man: Yeah, and I go to
your data-vocabulary.org
and read the exact specs to what
I should be putting on there.
Jordan:
So data-vocabulary.org is great,
but if your goal
is Rich Snippets,
at least
in my personal experience,
editing and adding
the structured markup,
the Webmaster Help Center pages
will give you an example,
like, "This is a Snippet that,
like, could give a Rich Snippet
on search engine results pages."
Does that make sense?
Whereas Data Vocabulary
is the spec,
and it's like
everything you can do,
the Webmaster page will say,
"This is something that--this is
a good example of the page
that would get
a Rich Snippet."
Daniel: It sounds like you have
a particular problem
that we're not serving
very well, so--
man: I think I'm too expressive,
and you're asking me
to just dumb it down for you,
and so I'm wondering how--
Jordan:
That's hard.
man: And so I'm wondering
how do you change for time?
I've heard, like,
"Oh, they notice
"when something comes up
in the testing tool
that didn't quite work out."
Kind of like
the forums question--
Do you tend to see
that that happened?
So, if I list Spinal Tap,
and I say bands like Spinal Tap,
and each of those has a little
person markup within them,
but the main object
is Spinal Tap,
and there's so many different
things you can do,
where it's all valid markup.
It's all very descriptive,
but it might take away
from you finding
the exact subject of the page.
Jordan:
So, to Daniel's point, yeah,
it sounds like that there is
a conversation to be had here,
and there's some changes
that we could make
to better address
your use case.
So, if you wouldn't mind,
come up afterwards,
and we'll talk about it
in more depth.
Yes?
man: I want to thank you
for the prayer times
in the Snippet.
Jordan:
Oh, you're welcome.
man:
I saw the talk this morning,
what places API from Geo.
So, the question,
of course, is,
how do we add
the places information
and inform through
the Webmaster site tools?
Daniel: So, I'm not sure
that I grasp your question.
Jordan:
I think the question is,
how can you add in
places information?
man: Places API that they
announced this morning
on Google Maps.
Jordan:
So, what's the end goal?
By adding in this information,
what do you want to see happen?
man: So, if I have a Website
that has got different events
at different locations or places
that I manage and control,
so I can upload
that information.
Jordan: So, there are
a number of different ways
that you can address
that problem,
and one of the ways
is to add Structured Markup.
And I believe
there is another way
that we can get local
information to Google as well.
Daniel:
Yes, the local story--
there are a couple
of different ways
to provide local information,
and one is through
Google Places itself.
Jordan:
Mm-hmm.
Daniel: There's a feed format
for local places.
So, if you want to use
the Places API today,
that's probably
the best place to do that.
man:
Okay.
Daniel: If your audience is more
a broader Web audience today,
the best place to do that
would be Markup on a Web page.
man:
Thank you.
Jordan:
And over here.
man: Hi.
I'm curious.
How many of the new HTML5 tags
will Google's search engine
recognize,
like, article,
section, nav,
footer, header,
things like that?
Jordan: In general,
we'd like to use
as much data as available,
and that includes all different
kinds of markup types.
And when we find
a good use case for that,
then we'll start
reading data.
I don't have any specific
information beyond that today.
Daniel: Yeah, the only thing
I'd add to that is
there's a difference
between the level of structure
that's expressed
and the level of richness
in those HTML5 standard tags
and those that are really
necessary to hoist
more information
onto the search results page
to make your page stand out,
to make your site stand out.
There really isn't much
that we have been able to do
with the article tags,
as they're used
on the Web today,
you know, because many people
use them incorrectly
or use them even on things
that aren't articles and so on.
So, that's something that
we're continuously looking at
in Search to see
how we can use them.
man: Hi. I was wondering
if you know to what degree
some of these technologies,
like Rich Snippet support
and PubSubHubbub
are supported in products
like the Google Search appliance
for Internet search,
so we can do this kind of thing
with our local content?
Jordan: So, maybe you could
speak to the search appliance,
but for custom search engine,
you definitely can use
Rich Snippets
to affect how those look on
your own custom search engine.
And, in fact, we take it
even a level further
with custom search engine
and give you even more control
over how everything looks,
using page--
Daniel: Page maps.
Jordan: Page maps.
That's the one.
Daniel: Yeah, sorry, I don't
know about how this relates
to the Google Search
appliance,
but I could take
your card afterwards
and put you in touch
with someone who might.
man:
Okay, thank you.
man: If we were to add
a PubSubHubbub Sitemap feed,
should we then remove
the old style standard Sitemap,
or should we keep them both?
Jordan: Well, so,
not everybody out there
is going to support
the feed and PubSubHubbub,
so it makes more sense
to include both
and just have your database
drive them,
so you don't need to
worry about them,
and then tell Google
about the one
that you want Google to use.
man: Got it. So, Google's
crawler can use both,
and you can say,
"Opt for this one."
Jordan: Yes.
man: Okay, and--
Jordan: Just indicate
that in Webmaster Tools,
which one you want Google
to use.
man:
Right.
I think that I've noticed
in the past,
you know, that we put a lot
of links on our Sitemap,
and Google
will crawl some of them,
but not necessarily
all of them.
If we use PubSubHubbub,
is that a good way to make sure
that at least the freshest stuff
gets crawled
more consistently,
or does it not necessarily
impact that?
Daniel: Right now,
it doesn't impact that at all,
but one of the advantages
of PubSubHubbub
is that Google
has tighter correlation
between when pages
change on your site
and when we know
pages change on your site.
So, that puts us in a situation
where we can, over time,
learn better page-change rates
than we can right now.
So, from a practical
perspective, it won't help you
get those pages indexed faster
right today,
but it puts us on a path where
we can do that in the future.
man:
Thank you.
Jordan:
Hi, Monica.
Monica:
Hello.
So, I love the support
for Microdata.
I was wondering if Google
would consider ever supporting
the Open Graph Vocabulary
with Microdata
and, in general, if you're
going to be supporting
the Open Graph Protocol
via Meta Tags at all
for this Rich Snippets.
Jordan:
Go for it.
Daniel:
Yeah, so Open Graph Protocol
is a type of RDFa.
It is a subset of RDFa,
so from a markup
language perspective,
there's really no barrier.
One of the--the deal,
as Timothy described it,
for Rich Snippets is a site
describes what their site
is about in more detail,
and in exchange, the site
gets richer results in Search.
So, right now
Open Graph Protocol
is not ideal for expressing
what a site is actually about.
It's very UI driven,
with the exception of locations
and the new effort
in products.
It's really focused on,
here's an image,
here's a title, here's
a description, here's a URL.
And we've found, over time,
that that doesn't--
communicating with users
in a search engine at that level
doesn't help people make
decisions of what to click on
on the search results page.
I think that makes a lot of
sense for the stream,
but makes less sense
on a search results page.
On a search results page,
having richer information
about, for instance,
ratings, for instance,
what--the specifics that
are encoded in a prayer time
is much more useful.
And, so, we haven't seen
that benefit right now,
but we're constantly
looking, right?
And there are
a significant number of pages
with Open Graph Markup,
so there's a lot to look at.
Monica: Okay, great,
thank you.
man:
So, Google tends to put
less emphasis
on invisible markup,
things that are like
in Meta Tags and the Head.
Yet Rich Snippets supports
things like Meta Elements
inside of your item.
So, I'm wondering, how do you
view a span versus a meta,
for example, if you're
to describe your data,
and things that might not be
very useful to the visitor
of your page,
like the Geo coordinates
or the war field,
in your example,
but could be interesting
in your Rich Snippet data?
So, how do you weigh
those decisions
and whether it just isn't ranked
that highly when you view it
and try to get information
versus what's not really useful
to a visitor?
Jordan: So, I'll take
a hack into that,
and then I'm sure
Daniel will add--
is that when you
look at a page,
the stuff that the user sees
is generally a better indication
of what that page is about
to that user,
and so, in general,
we encourage Rich Snippets
to mark up data that is,
in fact, visible to the user.
Daniel: Yeah,
I would only add that,
as you mentioned, in the case
of, say, Geo coordinates,
there are some cases where
that doesn't apply so well.
Yeah, so we look
at the information
that's on a Meta Tag,
but we really encourage it
to mark up the content
that the viewer sees.
Jordan:
Cool.
Well, I guess we got no more
questions for the microphones.
We'll go ahead and end here.
And I know I,
and I think Daniel,
will be around
for a little bit longer,
if you have any questions
for us directly.
Thank you so much.